welcome back to CBS Morning storms in
California are posing extreme danger
today more than 24 trillion that's right
trillion with a t gallons of water have
fallen from the sky since the beginning
of the year think about that for just
one second even so it's still not enough
to stop another threat to the region the
latest U.S monitor data shows an
improvement in drought conditions but
more than 97 percent of California is
currently experiencing at least moderate
drought and that is a big big problem
for our food supply California produces
more than a third of the nation's
vegetables in nearly three quarters of
its fruits and nuts meteorologist Evelyn
Taft from our station KCAL news joins us
from Los Angeles without Californians or
respondents are responding because
Evelyn we all want the broccoli good
morning we all want the broccoli that's
right I know I do Gail and good morning
and you know before that atmospheric
River hit California we went to the
state's largest agricultural region the
San Joaquin Valley people there have
long bolstered the water supply by
pumping from underground basins but as
we discovered that practice is creating
a literal race to the bottom
what's the biggest struggle right now as
a farmer well it's it's water and what's
Otherwise Known is the breadbasket of
the world Acres upon Acres of barren
fallow land and California's San Joaquin
Valley tell a harrowing story We form
about ten thousand acres just ask
William Bordeaux he's the Executive Vice
President of Harris Farms one of the
largest operations in the region
unfortunately it looks very desolate and
dry and depressing right now but with
water we could be growing watermelons
cantaloupes lettuce tomatoes and it just
changes the whole look and feel of the
farm agriculture is a booming industry
here employing around 420
000 people across the state and
supplying more than 400 different types
of crops to Consumers around the world
but amid historic drought conditions in
the west access to water has been
increasingly limited rain and snow are
hard to come by Reservoir levels are at
record lows rivers are drying up
enter groundwater pumping the practice
accounts for roughly 10 percent of water
use in the San Joaquin Valley and while
experts say people here have been
overdrafting from natural underground
basins for years
some argue it's a necessity to survive
the whole process of this drilling
system is called reverse circulation
Derek grabo is a sixth generation well
driller in the old days he told us
usable water was just 60 to 100 feet
beneath the surface but now for good
water we're going about thousand to 1400
feed deep average for us groundwater
accumulates since Subterranean bodies of
porous rock or sediment called aquifers
but generations of pumping have left
them significantly depleted nearly
two-thirds of California's monitoring
Wells are below normal level the process
went unregulated until the passage of a
2014 state law that aims to end
overdraft by the 2040s in the interim
though persistent drought has yielded a
well-drilling frenzy grabo can barely
keep up so what's it take to get a well
what what's what's the weight look like
uh the weight for us right now I believe
it's about a year out if not longer what
does it look like in a non-drought year
in a non-drought year I haven't seen
that what do you say to the people who
are saying you know we this is a finite
resource we can't drill oh yeah no we
have to and you know what what this what
sucks the most is uh of course the
farmer the dairyman the customer is
paying for it Bravo told us his Wells go
for as much as half a million dollars a
pop and for some consumers the cost is
closer to home than the grocery store
the water supply is going real low Jesus
Benitez has been living in the city of
Visalia for 14 years he told us the
domestic well that supplies water to his
property only works sporadically because
a nearby Farms industrial pump draws
water from the same source as a result
Benitez says his trees are drying up
what used to be a front lawn is long
gone at times even self-care and
household chores are a challenge day at
home look like it's it's really problem
you know because I had to tell my wife
you know hey don't watch the the
glossary now because they're putting
water does it feel Fair
no it doesn't I guess I started drinking
water from the bottle resorting to
bottled water may not just be a question
of scarcity right now in California we
have over 1 million Californians without
Safe Drinking Water the majority of
these residents are low-income people of
color Susana dionda is the executive
director and co-founder of the community
Water Center she told us groundwater
pumping has led to rampant pollution
making some water unsafe for consumption
the Central Valley is beautiful we grow
food here but we also use a lot of
fertilizer and that contributes to
Nitric contamination however we don't
just have nitrates we have a variety of
other contaminants just here at Mr
Benitez home he has nitrous and uranium
meanwhile local water districts have
begun to put limits on groundwater
pumping farmer William Bordeaux sits on
the board of his water district it's the
largest in the country I do feel
strongly that we need to come together
as a water community and work together
and overcome these challenges there's
plenty of opportunity for all of us to
succeed
California's Department of Water
Resources says the state could lose up
to 10 percent of its water supplies over
the next two decades according to one
estimate squeeze water access could
force farmers in the San Joaquin Valley
to take 500 000 acres of land out of
production and even with the recent rain
the groundwater Supply in California May
Never Fully recover Vlad
as you say Evelyn the opportunity is
there the question is is there will uh
thank you very much and say hi to our
friend Jamie yukas you guys are working
together now yes
good to see you good to see you good to
see you